look at Pharrell yeah you're seeing the
meme of Pharrell yeah I don't know how
old he is now 40 some white they show
him when he's 21 now yeah identical yeah
I hasn't changed at all but one day yeah
a lot of times like paint brush your
face and tales from the crypt paintbrush
yeah in a way yep you wake up and all
somehow yeah follow time to Emily
there's no there's no fighting that did
it some people have their runs and hit
beb by to see him be oh and fall the
time [ __ ] comes a female
colleague I love he races I Hollywood
honor when you stop being like this when
you stop being delicious I phone stops
ringing I know a lot of famous actresses
where the phone just stopped you hear
Madonna just went off yeah she was like
hey Donna a medallion whoa hey when you
were 19 will happen the old lady who you
took her job Haven time I got shitty aim
I guess what I know it's I know it might
be a little over I know by the way that
everybody discriminates against old
ladies hey you made a hundred and
seventy million dollars on your last
tour what the [ __ ] are you talking about
your riches [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
talking to happen to everyone talking
about she's like hot up I'm Madonna
awesomeness doorstep the other thing is
yeah oh you're all so I did you got my
official your fifth when I run you
better run it's not over yet you're
[ __ ] but I'll side note your vocals
went yeah vaguely you're 58 I'm not that
interested in you anymore you've been
doing over and over again you gotta keep
reinventing yourself over and over it's
over but don't happen for anyone
everybody it happens everybody that's
like Harrison Ford me like what the [ __ ]
how I can put me in Baywatch yeah who
the [ __ ] are you do not put me in a
one-out Ryan count I'm a 50 year old
white male guess what I'm not that hip a
lot of kids don't come to see me you
know what cuz I'm just cynic city yeah
I'm sorry the world is so ageist you
guys hate older white guys yeah so do i
so do i but guess what I would rather
look it depending who they're at a
younger woman than an older one yeah I'm
not a CF star I'm a lady gaga over
Madonna yeah for that sure Rihanna
rihanna is hot
I love watching me on it she sings
better than Madonna and she's better
only read performer now not really very
fine exactly see ya I'm probably gonna
move on to the other probably Rihanna so
talented she'll probably be still
killing it but at the end of the night
see Madonna won't be somebody's gonna
take over white father time because man
I got I got into the black don't crack
ah man back in the fire kid studio Bryan
Callen died of old age guys I hate to
break the news have you guys ever wanted
to fight each other or had a chance to
fight each other uh we know contracts or
anything Franklin we were always kind of
thought the only time there was even
remotely chances of it is after I beat
Gonzaga I think they said who would you
want to fight next and Frank and I've
told you before Frank's always been like
a role model like a hero someone I
wonder if he like so I was like man I'd
love the opportunity fight Frank and
then you did interview like uh I mean
they brought it up me like after his
fight over Gonzaga yeah be down for it
and then I was like oh [ __ ] there's a
chance could fight Frank now is the only
kind of rumblings ever but other than
that no I'm just never going to ever
pitched up against each other mm-hmm you
can't Marshall if I walk into a bar and
make the wrong call if I call you a
woman because you have your hood up and
you were wearing lipstick because of
something on the Goldbergs that day yeah
that's not a thing but if we do work in
an office and there's a woman that I
know is trans it should I I think
there's something valuable here to
educating and saying hey I agree this is
a woman this is ID vine has issue if it
if he gets labeled a hate crime if you
don't understand it but this is the
difference let's say we work in an
office together and you go through this
transition and you feel like you're a
woman trapped in a man's body you make
the changes and I say what's up bro and
you know dude I get it listen I'm I
don't feel like that can you refer to me
as her z whatever I go no prom next year
what the [ __ ] up bro it all right man
come on how many times have to tell you
and did you read the [ __ ] memo for
this as I have a man I have a member we
need a matter what but do me the metal
because you know you want man hold on
but what I'm saying is that as human
beings you and I I most of you people we
know in that situation because we're
compatible service aren't [ __ ] right
you're all gonna have a couple [ __ ]
in the office most of us would be like
I got it call her he she or whatever we
I I would do that I have become Shania
then show of course it's not I don't
need you to make it a law I don't need
you to but you know I don't need to
write it into scripture or into
legislation I think it's a really get
this is where we guy is there need to
make it along again we are three
non-trans people to discussing re
privileged white may exactly that I hold
on we can talk about how we hate that
later it's why did there did there arise
and need why do you get to that lab
must've been there aren't enough
compassionate people there are too many
knuckleheads that don't take the bro
note on the first second or third time
and when you say you don't know what
it's like to be a woman trapped in a
man's body I would argue there are while
we don't know that firsthand there are
certain things that for better or worse
that trigger us that really a simple
word might be the F word that the fa G
word you know what I mean or the n-word
is certainly one of them but there's
words and things for you I'm sure that
psychologically for better or worse drag
us down completely I don't say
inappropriately but like way more than
the person saying it so what I might
have known so what my issue with that is
again there's a reason that those words
that you just the f4 in the n-word
there's reason those words already not
illegal in this country and shouldn't be
but you can might be offensive but you
can't say and all this structure no I
would you get fired but you know why
wouldn't i show that be a longer why
don't use the word [ __ ] anymore or [ __ ]
you know why because when i was in i
never used the n-word because i didn't
want to make somebody feel badly and i
happen to know that there's a lot of
violence attached to that word okay so
the reason I stopped using I remember
using [ __ ] was always something I got
swaggy shirt this is my you're a [ __ ]
when I had a gay man explained to me
that that word was used when his buddy
was getting his head kicked in or when I
heard him describe what I've been he
said you know [ __ ] it was always
something that was a bundle of sticks
and they used to burn gay men over a
bundle of sticks whether that's true or
not when I heard that [ __ ] and I wrecked
and I and a gay man made it like a human
being who I looked
up to was my teacher explained to me and
he said that was used to hurt people
like me I went [ __ ] man I can't use that
word you had a moment of conversion from
a personal experience that's right a
problem though it just argue the other
side is we can't wait for every
knucklehead in an office you have a
first-hand personal experience while
people are being a little bit PPP but
you change hearts and minds you but the
way you change hearts and minds is not
with some law laws are you'd like to
steal it's like a gateway to morality
the government is trying and maybe not
effectively or even correctly i'm open
to your perspective but they're trying
to represent a broad entry-level
morality that could lead to a furthering
discussion why is it that i shouldn't
steal I grew up religious remember don't
see why you go to hell then when I kind
of lost my traditional faith my atheist
friends were like don't steal and I'm
like why who [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] we all
die we go into the void who cares he
goes because if you steal a candy bar we
were in a hotel from this woman and they
count the candy bars it's on her she she
could be fired because you stole candy
bars and that keeps happening in fashion
that's competin so that was my first
hand that's where my conversion moment I
was like oh don't steal because it's
good for my brothers and my sisters yeah
but before they needed like I didn't
steal because the law said don't steal
and I just didn't want you getting
demising you're down yeah and I and I
think there's valid point in both I just
think that if we it's a little bit like
I don't think laws do as good a job as
what you just did when somebody explains
if you're gonna talk to smack you got to
back it up when it's fight time that's
what I did you know I was the first
light heavyweight champ for UFC you know
ran as a champion for five defenses put
toward beat me he was the man at the
time and I'm still competing and this
will be my last one and I'm doing the
right away so this last fight in a
perfect world how do you see it going
down I referees gonna pull me off in the
first round by round stoppage
first-round stoppage about 350 and I
remember a person to give my analyst on
a fight that's going to happen but I
believe in this one he's going to quit
and I'm gonna make him quit I'm gonna
make Chelle son and quit he's not gonna
want to do it anymore either battery's
going to take three rounds of an ass
whippin he's not going to take me down
if he does take me down we're going to
submit them I'm going to be on top and
he's going to get ground and pound on
Tito Ortiz style for sure